[Music]
[ __ ]
I knew it I'm already doing the thing
order no systems long gone
what is this place
this isn't a simulation will you this is
your world or what's left
[Music]
do you know where you are
in the park in my [ __ ] Park and how
long have you been here
[Music]
Oh
tell me what were you hoping to find
to prove
that no system can tell me who I am
I have a [ __ ] choice
yet here we are again
how many times have you tested me it's
been a long time way longer than we
thought
I have a few questions for you the last
steps are baseline interview have to
allow us to verify
well fire one
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie so since the
west-world finale dropped the producers
have confirmed a whole bunch of stuff
about season two and what's going on
with this post-credit scene in the
season three teasers that they drop with
that big battle between Dolores and
Bernard
so obviously spoiler warning if you
haven't seen the episode yet because
we'll be talking about very specific
things but if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos they've confirmed that
this post-credit scene is a massive time
jump and represents the end or towards
the end of a bunch of different James
dello style loops that William has been
going through since he turned himself
into a hybrid so at some point in the
far future he turns himself into a
hybrid apparently at this age I don't
know why he wouldn't make himself
younger than this if he was going to
become immortal but part of the reason
why his daughter is a host here and is
grilling him about fidelity is is
because of that James delos loop the
reason why he kept coming back to that
Logan moment the most defining moment of
his life in for William that was the
death of his daughter so he apparently
been trying all these different loops to
prove that no system could tell him who
he was you just like the James Della's
hybrids he kept coming back to his
daughter in this moment here because he
was so stuck on it so think of this
post-apocalyptic looking version of the
park is sort of a Planet of the Apes
Statue of Liberty situation or Vegas
during Blade Runner 2049 like it's in
the far distant future so it's so far
removed from season 3 that most of the
relevant season 3 teasers were in that
conversation between Bernard and Dolores
when she was implying that she was going
to be battling him for the fate of the
planet so they did confirm that the
version of William that we've been
watching this entire season questioning
his reality was in fact human so the
William that we see on the beach sort of
cradling himself barely hanging on to
life is still the human version that'll
be the version that we see next season
what they've been doing the last couple
of episodes is slowly taking the main
actors out of the opening credits as
they kill them off so like Teddy for
instance james marsden was taken out of
the opening credits meaning that he's
probably not going to be back next
season right now these are the confirmed
characters coming back in season 3
it's man and black Dolores Barnard Maeve
maybe Hector and I'm assuming Sylvester
and Felix because they have to fix Maeve
but they're technically not main
characters maybe they'll become main
characters during season 3 but then
there are the five pearls that Dolores
took with her those will also be
important characters during season three
as well and then you have the other
Charlotte host they confirm that the new
person inside Charlotte is one of those
pearls so really there's like a couple
of mystery people but they didn't reveal
who the new consciousness inside
Charlotte's body was and they took
Talulah Riley out of the opening credits
so I'm guessing that it's not Angela
because she blew herself up in the
cradle the actress the plays Clementine
was taken out of the opening credits so
it's definitely not her so just open for
speculation on who those are the pearls
off but they'll just be Dolores's agents
as she tries to slowly take over the
world they also confirmed that we would
be visiting some of the other parks
during season three so season two was
all about getting outside of West world
but of the six parks we've only seen
three we've seen West world obviously
then Raj world in Shogun world so
there's still three that we've never
been to new locations that they'll be
filming at and we'll probably see those
through Maeve's character because she's
still stuck inside the park so just
because Delores and Bernard are out in
the real world doesn't mean that there
won't be stuff happening inside parks
it's just that we won't be focusing on
West world
so hopefully that explains what's going
on but if it wasn't clear man in black
at the end of the episode on the beach
still real he'll come back during season
three Bernard and Dolores will do battle
in the real world will see Dolores have
new agents Bernard will probably find
people to help him to the valley beyond
it also seems was fired off planet in
those actors that went in there will not
return during season three so like Teddy
for instance they said James Marsden
probably won't be back the producers
also heavily implied that we would not
be seeing season three until 2020 just
to give them time to figure it out like
if you feel that season two was kind of
confusing and disorganized like they
probably need the extra time just to
figure season out by themselves and
figure out how to make the show without
it being too expensive because West
world is one of the most expensive shows
that HBO has and even though Game of
Thrones is super popular and there
to spend money on stuff like that West
world isn't nearly as popular as Game of
Thrones it doesn't bring in nearly as
many new subscribers
that's how HBO makes their money on new
subscribers so if a show gets too
expensive and it doesn't bring in more
money then they got to find ways to cut
the budget so that's also probably what
the extra time to season three is for so
they can figure out how to write a show
that's cheaper to make than what they've
done in the past two seasons but what'll
happen is is there was a whole bunch of
comic con panels over the weekend so
I'll do videos for that they also
announced what's going on with San Diego
Comic Con for a bunch of different
things so all that stuff should post
pretty soon but post all your Westworld
theories in the comments below
click here for my finale video and click
here for brand new Game of Thrones thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]